Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
with regards to
the topic of theed of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and the tohed and the
aspect of
the aspect of the oneness of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala which was most
contended
by the
antagonist of all of the prophets and
messengers.
Every one of them came with this as the
main focus
of their message to humanity.
And every one of the prophets and
messengers
were fought against
and
rebelled against.
And the main issue of contention
was always not the belief
in the oneness of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala,
belief in the existence of Allah
and belief in
the oneness of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
in his existence that he subhanahu
wa'ta'ala in a general sense is the only
creator of the heavens and the earth and
the only sustainer and maintainer and
sovereign king of all that exists.
Subhanahu wa tala.
That is an issue that the majority of
humanity have always believed in. Why?
Because not only is that something that
is the logical
thing that a person would arrive at,
but as well
that not only is it logical, but it is
positively illogical to believe in
anything else.
And so if a person were to believe that
there is more than one creator
and that these creators are independent
of one another
and that they have equal ability
and power and authority
to
execute that will
then this creation would not have come
into being. I mean, think about it just
in a very logical way.
One wants to make it rain, the other
wants to make it sunny. What are we
going to do now? In a very simple way,
this is something that
is a given that all of humanity
in a logical sense
very rarely do we have people or
civilizations
throughout human history that do not
believe in a creator at all. They
believe that all of this came out of
nothing or came out of a mindless
set of random events. This is incredibly
illogical and it is something that
borders on insanity.
Nor do
people naturally believe that there is
more than one equal creator of the
heavens and the earth.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
He says, "Subhanala,
if there were more than one creator,
then each of the creators would take his
respective creation and both attempt to
gain authority and highness over one
another. It's not possible.
However,
the issue
and the point of contention is always
the worship of that one creator alone
without any partners.
If you think that belief in the
existence of a creator
is unique and is what makes Islam unique
from amongst the rest of the religions
of the earth, this is incorrect. That is
mistaken. This is something which is a
given even to the polytheists and the
idoltors of Mecca in the time of the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
they accepted this they accepted that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is the creator
alone without any partners the issue was
the worship of Allah alone
and the issue and point of contention
was that there is no intercession that
is forced upon Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
so when we read through the Quran Allah
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
the belief of those who worship these
idols and claim that they are saints or
individuals of high position and stature
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. He says
subhanahu wa ta'ala that they claim
they say regarding their idols, their
saints, their graves, whatever it is
that they worship their angels.
They say these are our interceders
with Allah on our behalf on the day of
judgment or in this dunya for those who
did not believe in the day of judgment.
However, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, he
has rejected this notion and and and
falsified it subhanahu wa ta'ala and
brought so many evidences logical and
otherwise in the Quran to refute this
idea.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in the Quran
when he speaks about intercession
there are times when you see Allah says
there is no intercession just that
there is no intercession
and then there are other places in the
Quran where Allah affirms intercession
and says that there will be intercession
on the day of judgment. What does that
mean? What does that mean? How do we
understand this? The scholars tell us
intercession.
Intercession with Allah on behalf of
another
in the Quran is two types.
They say that intercession is two types
that is mentioned in the Quran. There is
intercession which is affirmed and
confirmed by Allah and there is
intercession which is negated by Allah.
What intercession is negated? When we
look through the Quran and we see
instances where Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says for instance
that on the day of judgment there's no
intercession. What intercession is he
speaking about? He's speaking about the
intercession
that the minds of the pagan Arabs first
goes to when the word intercession is
brought up. that intercession does not
exist. And that is the intercession of
their idols, the intercession of their
gods.
that if I get on this God's good side,
if I worship this idol, if I worship
this saint, this grave, this person
or thing, then this thing will intercede
on my behalf on the day of of judgment
because I will be considered of its
constituents.
That is
negated by Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
And when Allah says in the Quran, there
is no intercession, he's speaking about
this intercession, the intercession that
is part of the ideology of the pagan
idoltors of the Arab Peninsula in the
time in which the Quran was revealed.
As for the intercession which is
affirmed by Allah, it's the intercession
that comes to our minds as Muslims
that we know of and that is the
intercession
of the prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam for instance on the day of
judgment the intercession of the
prophets on behalf of their nations. The
intercession of a martyr on behalf of
his family. The intercession of a child
who passed away in youth for his parents
or her parents. The intercession of the
angels even the intercession of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. This all which is
found throughout the Quran found
throughout the sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. This intercession
is affirmed by Allah.
But it is intercession
that is by the permission of Allah. No
intercession is forced on Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. It is intercession
of those whom Allah permits to intercede
and it is intercession only on behalf of
those who worship Allah alone without
any partners. There is no intercession
on behalf of someone who worships other
than Allah. These are the three
conditions mentioned by Allah. Subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
He says, "And innumerable amounts of
angels
in the heavens
and these angels cannot intercede on
behalf of anyone. Even if they all
collaborated to intercede on one
person's behalf,
they can only intercede
for those whom Allah allows
and intercede after Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has given permission in.
So this is the tohedited. This is the
aspect of
in which the main contention
occurred between the messengers and
their people. Were there anomalies
throughout the time? Yes.
Pharaoh for instance,
he rejected the notion of a creator. He
rejected
that idea. But that was only a claim, an
outward rejected rejection. Allah tells
us in his heart of hearts, he believed
that and he believed nothing different.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala said
he says that outwardly they rejected it
but Pharaoh and his in their hearts
and in themselves were certain of it.
They were certain of what Mus Alisam was
calling them to and that is not only the
belief in the oneness of Allah but the
practice of the oneness of Allah meaning
the worship of Allah alone without any
partners. And for this reason, this is
why the statement that we make in order
to enter into Islam and proclaim our
Islam
is not
belief merely in the existence of Allah.
Rather, it is belief in
the right of Allah alone, the sole right
of Allah alone to be worshiped.
Subhanahu wa'ta'ala. So we sayahill
meaning none is rightfully worshiped but
Allah anything or anyone else who is
worshiped aside from Allah it has no
right to be worshiped.
None is rightfully worshiped but Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
This was put so eloquently by
or and also by
Hanfi
and his explanation of
Abhani.
Perhaps some of some of us have heard of
him. maybe most of us have not but he
was one of the most prominent students
of Ib the
and he has his most famous work and his
most cited book that he penned which
is
of the explanation of
in this explanation He sums up this
in a beautiful way. He says,
[Silence]
He says two types of
no one will obtain salvation and none
will attain redemption
or success in this life and the
hereafter without both types of
[Silence]
he says these two types of these two
types of oneness
then is the of the messenger
and theed
of the one who sent that messenger.
It's a very eloquent way of summing that
up that these two types of oneness a
person must uphold in his life in this
life. In order for a person to attain
salvation,
you must maintain oneness of the
messenger and oneness of the one who
sent the messenger. What does he mean by
that?
Oneness of the one who sent the
messenger. Meaning oneness of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. He's the one that
sent the messenger.
And this is contained in the statement
in the first pillar of Islamahill.
None is rightfully worshiped but Allah.
This is the first
of the one who sent the messenger.
Meaning that only Allah is rightfully
worshiped.
And anyone or anything who is worshiped
in any way
has no right to that worship. That's the
first type. The second type he tells us
the oneness of the messenger
and that is contained in
with the first pillar of Islam. I
testify that none is rightfully
worshiped but Allah and I further
testify that Muhammad is the messenger
of Allah
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. What does
this mean? This means that only Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam is obeyed and his
words inherently are evidence from
amongst humanity.
It is only the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Everyone
else who is followed, everyone else
whose legacy is adhered to is only
followed and adhered to in the adherence
to his sunnah sallall.aii wasallam. So
the prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam speaks, he commands
something, he prohibits something, he
does something, his words inherently are
evidence in themselves.
And
as long as we understand that this is
from him and that these are his words,
then we follow that
and we adhere to it.
Whether we understand the wisdom behind
it or not, inherently his words are
evident
from amongst humanity. Anyone else, it
is conditional.
We obey anyone else from amongst
humanity
only under the condition
that it not conflict with the obedience
of Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam. that
his obedience not conflict with the
sunnah of the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
And we will end with a statement of our
prophet sallall.aii wasallam Ahmed. He
says,"He
said, I swear by Allah that if MS were
alive today and amongst you, he would
have no other choice but to follow me
and adhere to my sunnah because he is
the messenger of our era and of this
nation. We will continue this inshallah
next week. We ask Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
that he teach us that which will benefit
us and that he benefit us from that
which he teaches us this time. And we
ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that he
make us of those who truly uphold the
oneness of Allah and adhere to the
sunnah of his messenger.
What?
Hey, thank you.
[Silence]
Allahbarb.
Allah
Heat. Heat.
What?
I said
I sh
Heat. Heat.
[Silence]
A shadow one.
I sh
[Silence]
I
I forat.
[Silence]
I love
heat.
Hey,
[Silence]
heat.
What?
Yeah.
Oh,
[Silence]
come on.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Muslim moon.
for
[Silence]
foram.
for
[Silence]
In these two verses in
this chapter of the Quran was the last
chapter to be revealed to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam in Mecca and the
first chapter to be revealed in Medina.
This chapter of the Quran marked the end
of an era and the beginning of another.
It marked the end of the era of Mecca,
the Meccan era.
And it marked the beginning of the
Medani era and the start and birth of
the new
Muslim
state of our prophet and his companion
Sam. Wasam.
In this chapter,
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala begins by
speaking about a type of person
and the chapter itself takes its
namesake
from this type of person which the
chapter begins with discussing
that is
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala begins the
chapter by saying
woe to the
meaning it is a threat.
It is Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
warning humanity warning his servants of
humankind and ginankind
from being from amongst those
because indeed a
is a lonely creature of Allah subhanahu
waala
that is in grave danger
of the anger and punishment of Allah.
Who are
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sums it up for
us and tells us that this type of person
is a person who is very petty.
A person who when he is seeking his
rights or what he believes is his from
others,
he seeks these rights in their totality
and he demands that everything that is
his be given to him.
Yet when it is time to give others their
rights,
he tries to shorthand them.
He does not give others their full
measure.
So this individual demands everything
that is his
and does not give everyone else what is
theirs
because he has a particular type of view
with regards to the other men and women
on this earth or creatures.
He feels or she feels entitled.
An entitlement
is a disease
and a hunger that cannot be satiated.
You can never feed an entitled person
enough
to satisfy them
because they have no sense of thanks.
They have no sense of gratitude.
Everything that they have, they earned
it and it is theirs in their mind
and that which others have should be
theirs.
And so
these
what is the danger truly of this way of
thinking and this kind of entitlement?
Entitlement.
those who wish to have all that is
theirs and don't wish others to have all
that is rightfully theirs. A person who
when they are to give others their
rights, they will short change them.
They will take a little extra and skim
off the top if they can get away with
it.
However, when it is time for them to
take what is theirs, they demand it in
full
and they cry out justice.
This kind of person,
this kind of person is found in all
facets of life.
A salesman who demands full price for
his merchandise but does not equally
demand that his merchandise be worth the
price he is asking.
A wife that demands her husband cater to
all of her rights.
However,
she is unwilling to fulfill the rights
of her husband.
And if she does, it is with great pains.
Or a husband that demands his full
measure from his wife, but does not wish
to give her her full rights.
A child which demands his or her full
rights and measure from his parents
but does not fulfill the rights of his
parents. And so on it goes.
This type of person, this type of
entitlement
is not just dangerous
because a person will come on the day of
resurrection owing everyone around him.
That's not the only reason it is
dangerous.
And that's not the only reason that
Allah mentions in this chapter.
15 woe
and warning and danger
for this type of entitled person.
That's not the only reason it's
dangerous, but because of the effects
that these sins have upon the heart.
Those little sins, those minor sins. The
word
in the Arabic language comes from that
little bit of extra that is above the
brim of a measurement.
When you look at a at a heaping cup for
instance, you take a cup of rice or a
cup of sugar and it is heaping that
little bit on top that goes beyond the
edge of the vessel that you would scrape
off the top. That little bit that comes
off that heap, that is a
that is that little extra bit.
And a mutiff is someone who is willing
to debase himself for that little few
grains.
It is someone who is petty enough
and lowly enough that they are willing
to risk and put their soul at hazard for
that little bit, for those few extra
pennies.
And so
these little bits, this little tufa,
these few pennies, these tiny sins,
these little from here and there and a
little bit here and a little bit there.
What effects does that have on the
heart?
These things accumulate on the heart of
the human being.
And these things will accumulate to the
point that they will blind a person's
heart.
So much so that a person will no longer
be able to distinguish truth from
falsehood.
We'll no longer be able to differentiate
between the words of Allah and the words
of a shaitan.
And this brings us back to the verse
which we began with
in
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala describes the
people of hell.
He describes the
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala says, "Woe to
the beliers, the disbelievers,
those who disbelieve
in the day of judgment."
What is Eden?
And the day of yen,
it is the day of precise judgment.
That is
the day of
is the day of precise and just judgment.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says, "Woe to
those who disbelieve in the day of that
precise judgment."
And it is truly only a person who is
transgressing
and a person who is sinful who will
choose to disbelieve in the day of
judgment.
This is the true motivation
of those who disbelieve in the judgment
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. It's not
because science has led them to their
atheism.
It is not because they truly believe in
their heart of hearts irrespective of
the implications
that there is no creator or that they
have
logically arrived at the conclusion
that all of this is for nothing.
That's not the reason they truly
disbelieve in the day of judgment. No.
Allah tells us that they disbelieve in
the day of judgment because they are
sinful and transgressing.
They want to transgress. They don't want
to have rules. They don't want to be
told this is right and this is wrong.
They want to enjoy themselves. They want
to exercise their free will to its
maximum.
They want to be free
and they want to be liberated morally
and ethically.
And so they want to lay down with
whoever they want. They want to put in
their belly and nourish their body with
whatever they want.
They want to cloud their mind and poison
their heart whenever they want and
however they choose without
that nagging guilty conscience. Who
wants that? Who wants to try to enjoy
themselves and have something a
conscience telling you this is wrong,
you shouldn't be doing this. That's no
fun. That's uncomfortable.
And so they disbelieve in the day of
judgment.
They think that if they stick their head
in the sand deep enough, if they close
their eyes hard enough, if they ignore
it
avidly enough,
and if they argue against the day of
judgment vehemently enough and get as
many people on their side as they can,
that will somehow secure for them
their cake while they eat it at the same
time. That's what they think. That's the
idea behind it.
And so they disbelieve in the day of
judgment. And Allah tells us it is only
a type of person who disbelieves in the
day of judgment. A person who is
a person who is sinful by nature and
transgressing. That is the driving force
for their conclusion.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then describes
the kind of person who is sinful
describes the
describes those who disbelieve in the
day of judgment.
He tells us subhanah
their heart has become so dark,
their heart has become so clouded
and their mind so perverted
that when our verses are recited upon
them, they dismiss our verses. verses
saying these are merely the fables and
mythologies of the previous nations.
Let us ponder upon that for a moment.
the absurdity of such a statement
that a person would hear the Quran,
the words of Allah
and confuse those words with the fables
and mythologies
of the previous nations.
Those who when they hear the story of
Ibraimisam,
those who hear the stories of Yunus,
the stories of Noah,
the stories of the prophets and
messengers,
the descriptions of paradise and hell,
the judgments and laws of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
When they hear these things, when they
are recited upon them, they dismiss them
and they say, "These are just the
mythologies that exist in every other
civilization."
Made up things, camp stories,
mythologies
of the east and west,
the Roman and Greek mythologies of
Zeus and Aries. absurdities, stories
that children would scoff at.
The idea that these
this creation in its perfection is
governed by a bunch of gods and these
gods came into power because they
overthrew gods before them.
and that these gods would do incredibly
absurd things that even children would
have a problem and a tough time
swallowing.
And so this is what
they believe in. They say that these
mythologies,
these stories are just the stories
in the Quran. No different.
Interesting
stories. for instance, that Zeus is the
king of the gods, whatever that means,
and that his mother was married to a
Titan god before him.
And that every time she would have a
child and bear a child for this Titan
god, he would come and eat this god and
eat the child because he's afraid that
this child's going to grow up and
overthrow it. These are gods we're
talking about.
And so what does she do when she has
Zeus? He's a little child, a baby.
She takes a a stone, a rock, and she
wraps it up and swallows it you
would an infant. And then when his
father comes, he takes the rock and he
eats it. and he thinks that he ate Zeus,
but really she hid him away somewhere
and she kept feeding him until he got
older.
So this god cannot distinguish between
an alive infant child and a boulder
wrapped up in rags.
And then he later comes and overthrows
his father
and cuts off his father's unmentionables
and all of the children that he had
before come out and start to grow out of
his forehead and they become the
Olympians, the gods that we are familiar
with today. That's a story. That's a
real story from these nations and
civilizations.
How in the world a person could confuse
such silliness
with the stories of Ibraim
who destroyed the idols with his own
hand as a child who asked his father,
"My father, you are the one who chisels
and fashions these idols
and then you worship them. But these
things depend on you to come into
existence.
Why do you worship that which has no
hearing and no sight and no ability to
help you? They confuse this and this.
And when they hear the words of Allah
Allah
and when they hear
they confuse that with these kinds of
stories. Why? How could a human being
confuse this and that?
How could they conflate the words of
Allah with the silly fables of a people
who worshiped everything but Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala? How?
The answer is
Allah tells us why they have confused
the words of Allah with the words of
aan. How did they confuse them? It's not
because the words of Allah or the
stories of the Quran are in any way
comparable
or
adjacent or in any way
similar to these fables and mythologies.
That's not the reason. He says the
reason is because of the rust that has
overtaken their hearts because of their
sin.
That is the reason that when a person
sins
and they continue to disobey Allah and
they do not repent and they do not
change their way and they continue to
practice
everything and do anything that they
want or desire
that this starts a speck of rust on
their heart. And if they continue down
that path, their hearts will become so
overwhelmed with this corrosion that
they will no longer be able to
distinguish the words of Allah from the
words of aan. It sounds the same to
them.
We ask Allah subhanahuaala
that he subhanahuaala
forgive us our sins that he grant us a
true repentance and that he subhanahu wa
ta'ala guide us the straight path
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Look for
in January.
Abu
narrates that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam has said if a person commits a
sin,
this sin will leave a speck a black dark
speck on his heart. And if the person
then seeks forgiveness and repents and
changes his ways and ceases this sin,
his heart will be purified and scrubbed
clean.
However, if a person continues down that
path and that sinfulness,
that speck will continue to spread like
rust on iron until he will find himself
as Allah has described. It is not that
they are confused with regards to the
verses of Allah. this verse that we
mentioned from
rather it is the lust and corrosion of
sin that has overtaken their hearts. We
ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that heal
grant us the insight and the wisdom and
enlightenment to recognize the truth
when we when we hear it. That he grant
us the courage to adhere and uphold that
truth. that he grant us the honor of
living and dying for and upon that
truth. And that he grant us the nobility
of being resurrected with the people of
that truth.
Allah.
foreign.
[Silence]
Allah.
for
[Silence]
Allah.
Allah
forham.
[Silence]
He was
alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Heat. Heat.
Yeah. Heat.
[Silence]
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Close all
of the gaps. Straightening the row is
part of it is incredibly important. The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam would show
so much attention to straightening the
rows and he would say that
He said that you will straighten your
roads or Allah will make your hearts
unaligned with one another and in
discord. And so
we have to straighten our rows. Please
check your phones. Make sure that they
are silent.
And I'm sure
alhamdulillah you
are
many.
So
you
be
[Silence]
Why you
got
[Silence]
Allah
Say Allah.
Allah.
[Silence]
Allah
Allah.
Alhamdulillah.
Walking
He canister
him.
Can I
dream
[Silence]
be
better.
Hello.
[Silence]
Allah
May Allah
Allahb
Allah
Allahbar.
Allahbel.
[Silence]
almost Surely.
Allah
salam.
[Silence]
Yeah, you have to just plug it into the
one with the tape on it.
[Silence]
I just have few announcement. we have
few programs that are available for you
to take advantage of and in particular
on Saturdays we have two programs that
happen simultaneously. One for the youth
boys and one for the ladies or the girls
and this is he Quran.
Please make sure that you take advantage
of that and you come and attend. It's
between 11:00 a.m. and 1:00 p.m. And
it's also the same for the sisters.
It's from 11:00 a.m. and 1:00 p.m.
Sister's upstairs, the boys are
downstairs.
Also, we have a
youth soccer program and this is for has
two groups ages 7 to u
I need to make this larger to 9 and then
we have another group from 10 to 12.
This is also happening inshallah
on Saturdays August 30th. So basically
tomorrow you can just come to here
inshallah and there will be somebody to
help you with that. Also a themed
the weekend school is off. There's no
weekend school this weekend. Okay.
One more reminder that we normally start
later with the tax credit, but the tax
credit program that helps the school
that costs you nothing. We already have
the new flyers for 2025. If you can
afford to pay it, which eventually does
not cost anything, please do take
advantage of that because that helps us
help our students here. And because of
the school schedule starts from August
to May, you know, it doesn't align
with the end of the year. But if you are
able to do any tax credit, you can see
the flyers back there or you can ask
me for any question.
And thank you